In the virtualized set up the hypervisor sits
between the guest operating system and the hardware.
So the picture gets a little bit complicated.
Inside each one of these operating systems of
course they use a level processes and each
process is in its own protection domain. What
that means is that in each of these
operating systems, there is a distinct page table
that the operating system maintains on behalf of the processes that are running
in that operating system, similarly in this case. Does the hypervisor
know about the page tables maintained on behalf
of the processes that are running in each one of these individual operating
systems? The answer is no. Windows and Linux are simply protection
domains distinct from one another so far as the
hypervisor is concerned. The fact that each of Windows
and Linux within them contain application of a processes
is something that the hypervisor doesn't know about at all.